we begin with some breaking news the
United States has carried out
retaliatory strikes in Syrian territory
after a drone attack in the country
killed the U.S contractor five American
troops and another contractor were
wounded according to the Pentagon the
U.S strike targeted groups with ties to
Iran operating in the eastern part of
Syria Holly Williams has more on this
Holly good morning good morning well we
are witnessing an escalation of violence
in Syria directly involving U.S forces
U.S officials say that a base in Syria
used by the American Military came under
rocket fire this morning there are no
initial reports of U.S casualties that
follows airstrikes overnight ordered by
President Biden targeting groups in
Syria aligned with Iran during Syria's
12-year long Civil War Iran's been
closely allied with the Syrian regime
these images are believed to show the
aftermath of some of the U.S strikes
they were retaliation for a drone attack
yesterday on a base used by U.S
personnel well in northeastern Syria the
Pentagon says the Drone used was of
Iranian origin killing that U.S
contractor five American Service members
and another U.S contractor were reported
injured now we've spent quite a bit of
time on bases used by U.S forces in that
area American troops went into Syria in
2015 to fight against the Islamic State
or Isis and around 900 U.S service
members are still based there the Syrian
conflict doesn't get much attention
these days but it is ongoing it's drawn
in the U.S Iran Russia and Turkey and as
these events show it's still deadly Tony
Holly thank you very much